ici avec toutes les crises qu'il
traverse actuellement les etats-unis
perdaient un peu de leur hégémonie
si à l'image de ce que l'on a vécu après
les deux guerres mondiales
le visage du monde était amené à changer
il ya d'abord la pandémie selon les
bilans officiels
les etats unis sont le premier pays
touché dans le monde
il compte aujourd'hui plus de 2 millions
de cas et près de 120 mille décès trump
tantôt alarmistes tantôt trop rassurant
on a été et continue d'être fortement
critiqué pour sa gestion de l'épidémie
les états unis paraissent donc affaibli
face à cette crise salutaire en ayant
échoué à endiguer la pandémie sur leur
territoire pendant que de son côté la
chine même si son bilan officiel et bien
souvent remise en cause est allé jusqu'à
apporter de l'aide aux pays les plus
touchés en asie au moyen-orient et même
en europe
trump a également dû faire face à la
montée des manifestations anti racistes
sur le territoire américain
8 sur toute la planète dressant le
visage d'une amérique où le racisme est
toujours présent et ancrer le contrecoup
du soft power américain négatif ou
positif ce qui se passe là-bas fini par
se globaliser et après un mandat de
trump et son fameux america first
autrement dit une amérique
- tourner sur le monde et plus vers elle
même une amérique du repli sur soi il ne
serait pas étonnant si la crise perdure
que les cartes de la géopolitique
mondiale finissent par être rebattues